the cave of knowledge a place that most
players accidentally walked right past
but didn't notice a glowing man in a
chair that tells you to take the plunge
now i would say most players are lucky
that they miss this cave while it houses
a vast array of knowledge that can help
the player begin their journey in the
lands between it houses one of the most
powerful enemies in the game during our
journey we fight against terrifying
creatures towering giants celestial
beings and literal gods all of which are
odds stacked heavily against the
tarnished as they are beckoned back into
the world for one purpose to fix what is
broken but there is one man in this
world that has no purpose and doesn't
want one a man who stands the tests of
time and has carefully crafted a plan to
change the world not for virtue or any
kind of reward but just for the simple
fact that he can this man controls
everything and he's doing it right under
our noses disguising himself as one of
the many so that he can carry out his
own will whenever he sees fit this man
may not look like much but his power
holds no bounds there is no limit to the
influence he can create seemingly out of
thin air there are warriors creatures
legends and even gods that roam the
lands between however this man's power
goes beyond all of them this man
is simply known
as the soldier of god and his name
is rick
the world of elden ring is in disarray
the queen has started a shattering that
has created a war among her demigod
children all battling for more power we
as the tarnish are tasked with defeating
these demigods obtaining their great
runes and using them to mend the elden
ring back together this is a very
daunting task but at least you can make
sure that you're well groomed by using
manscaped before you set off on your
journey rick himself uses manscape to
look and feel fresh before putting these
demigods in their place the perfect
package kit comes with the lawnmower 4.0
which is a skin safe electric trimmer to
reach your peak performance it also
comes with anti-chafing deodorant ball
spray toner and disposable shaving mats
to clean up those pesky tarnished pews
it makes you smell so good that you'll
never be maidenless ever again if you
use code agt jake you'll receive 20 off
your order and receive some free gifts
including a travel bag and manscaped
anti-chafing boxers to keep your
tarnished tackle right where it's
supposed to be check out the manscaped
link in the description and in the
pinned comment to learn more this is our
first official sponsor here on the
channel so click the link and use the
code to make your journey through the
lands between run as smoothly as
possible thank you manscape for
sponsoring this video
rick has a lot of responsibilities to
bear don't think of him as an outer god
but as the god he directs all sources of
life from animals to the outer gods
themselves that's a lot of life to make
sure it all falls into his plan rick's
plan does not result in anything in
particular when you have the power that
rick holds you don't need a plan to go
one way or the other it falls into place
as it does it simply is what it is for
rick because nothing affects him nothing
can hurt him but he is aware that his
choices and actions do affect the lands
between
and all that inhabited imagine having
that responsibility on your shoulders
having no agenda no good nor evil just
simply being rick what would you do you
know the goats in limb grave that
randomly start rolling rick gave them
that ability to roll simply because he
thought it was funny he even gave this
ability to certain giants around the
area as well but there's obviously much
more to being a god than making animals
randomly roll while rick didn't create
any of the outer gods that came to the
lands between he did alter their path
without them even knowing of his
existence in fact he didn't want them to
know who he was he wanted to observe to
see what would happen the greater will
took over the great tree that came
before it traces of the great tree and
its crucible followers can still be
found around and below the lands between
rick saw that the greater will and its
golden order were egotistical they
thought of themselves as perfect and
anything that came to defy their order
would be quickly destroyed by their most
powerful lords rick sat back and watched
godfrey and his warriors battle against
everyone from the ancient dragons to the
giants rick found it interesting that
beans had to fight and showcase their
power at all times he thought of the
greater will as wannabe gods as a true
god like himself wouldn't have to
constantly show off their power and
order however
rick did find it interesting to watch he
could see that their imperian queen
america was starting to lose faith rick
had never known what it was like to even
have faith so he took an interest in
america's feelings she had everything
order power influence and yet she
started to devise a plan to destroy what
gave her all of that rick wanted to be a
part of this to understand why she would
do something like this maybe it was like
the goats just wanted to mix things up a
bit eventually america's plan had begun
she ordered malaquette to seal away
destined death her children had all left
the golden order for their own ideals
she allowed ronnie to slay her own
empyrean flesh and destroy the soul of
one of her own children rick would see
the anguish this caused queen america
though he didn't understand why she
would do all of it if it would hurt
herself in the process while rick was
still somewhat confused he let her
continue with her plan and eventually
she unraveled everything and shattered
the elden ring this set the world into a
frenzy wars from all over started yet
again and america's children sought
after their own power under their own
agendas the shattering of the elden ring
awoke the tarnished that were revived in
order to seek the shard bearers and mend
the elden ring back together rick took a
special liking to the tarnished and
wanted to give them a proper welcome to
their seemingly impossible task rick
stowed himself in the cave of knowledge
awaiting the tarnished under the name of
soldier of godric now obviously rick
couldn't use his full power against a
recently awoken tarnished they wouldn't
even understand the scope of power they
were really fighting against so rick
would send a clone of himself that would
instill a sense of hope into the
tarnished it would be their first step
on an incredible journey that rick just
wanted to be a part of simply because
it was interesting to him he wanted to
help the tarnished so rick set off to
see what he could do with the shard
bears before the tarnish would go up
against them ronnie and radon had been
in a previous altercation before the
shattering radon learned of ronnie's
plan to destroy her imperian flesh and
kill her two fingers so out of brotherly
love for his sister radon used his
powerful gravity magic to place ronnie's
two fingers among the stars out of her
reach radon was extremely powerful and
the tarnish stood absolutely no chance
so rick devised an interesting plan rick
knew of moog's intentions to start his
own dynasty under another outer god
known as the formless mother however
moog needed an empyrean to be the vassal
or their outer god moog's best chance
was with another imperian known as
mykola it was located at his helic tree
to the far north mykolo was growing his
halo tree from his own flesh which
morphed out of his cocoon that he was
sleeping in he was attempting to create
another tree in order to cure his sister
melania of her affliction the scarlet
rot which slowly eats away at her body
she was the blade of mikala and she
wasn't afraid to tell people that
melania was the only other demigod that
stood a chance at weakening the state of
radon's power and it just so happened
that moguin's palace was located
directly below radon's battleground so
rick instilled the knowledge of nicholas
location to moog once the shattering
began and the warring started moog went
to the halo tree and plucked out mikla's
cocoon and took him back to moguin's
palace melania returned to the haley
tree to find mickala gone and went on a
ruthless search for him eventually
landing her in the caled wilds she could
sense mikala's presence near radon and
battled against him in order to find her
brother radon loved war and would never
turn down a fight against someone like
melania their battle was legendary but
radon was clearly bettering melania so
at a snap of rick's fingers he allowed
melania's scarlet rot to bloom after
stabbing radon this infected radon with
the scarlet rot weakening his power and
giving a chance of success for the
tarnished as for melania she was taken
back to the halo tree to recover and
await the hopeful return of mykola
however rick knew that her abilities
would be seen as total [ __ ] by the
tarnished he knew he would need to
weaken her as well so in an effort to do
this without giving away who he truly
was rick put melania into a deep sleep
where she would dream of fighting a
soldier of godric over and over again
corpse after corpse left in her wake but
could never truly be rid of a simple
soldier that would just keep coming back
she would defeat this soldier but his
relentlessness of coming back time and
time again drove her insane each time
she would fight with the soldier her rot
would spread throughout her body more
and more eventually spreading over her
eyes causing her to go blind you didn't
know this while in a deep sleep and by
the time the tarnished had found her
there was nothing she could do about the
rot over her eyes she would be forced to
fight without sight giving the tarnished
a chance at beating her everything else
was set and put into motion for rick to
watch the tarnish try and become the
elden lord it was exciting for rick to
watch someone with seemingly no power
whatsoever try and grasp even a fraction
of what rick was capable of if rick
wanted to he could just end everything
with the snap of his fingers but there's
no excitement in that is there with the
tarnished rick felt something that he
wished he had
purpose
rick was everything but he felt like
nothing at the same time he needed the
tarnish to succeed just so he could feel
what it was like to have a purpose and
actually succeed in that purpose so rick
paved the way for the tarnished every
step along the way and all he had to do
was let the tarnished slay a clone of
him a single time in the cave of
knowledge rick allows the tarnish to
fight against a clone of himself while
it was meant to boost their ego at the
start of their long journey it also
coded the tarnished with a fragment of
rick's blood this blood allowed the
tarnished ungodly determination on their
journey if the tarnish were up to the
challenge if they continued onward
through adversity eventually they would
always come out victorious however if
the tarnish were to give up or make
excuses or quit along their journey then
rick would remove his blood coating
making the journey harder for the
tarnished in particular now most of
these hollowed tarnish would use bleed
weapons to beat the game which made rick
sick to his stomach because it was
clearly super overpowered and to watch
something like that was depriving he
knew that their honor would be slandered
after this so he paid no mind to them
eventually the tarnish would reach the
elden ring would they become the new
elden lord and just take the throne for
themselves maybe usher in an era of
darkness with the blue doll that they
simped over or would they simply burn
everything down and for some reason like
their head on fire as well this always
fascinated rick why some tarnish would
just watch everything burn
but if that's what they wanted then it's
what rick wanted too rick was not a fan
of gideon off near a man claiming to
know everything rick would laugh to
himself every time the all-knowing would
refer to himself as such rick must have
been doing a good job at hiding in the
shadows if someone like him never even
knew of rick's true power however
gideon's final words after being
defeated by the tarnished
in my
bones
a tarnished
cannot become
a lord
not even you
a man
cannot
kill
a god
and gideon was right a man cannot become
a god not at least without some help
from one
thank you all for watching the video
this one was really fun to make again
another huge thank you to manscape for
being our first official sponsor here on
the channel that's a really big deal to
me because i've always loved their
products i've been using manscape for
years so make sure to click the link
below and use the code to get a discount
and some free gifts special thank you to
my patrons who give me the extra support
to make content like this they get early
access to these videos with no ads so if
you're interested in that you can go
check it out in the description i always
give them a shout out in every video so
thank you again to all the patrons that
you can see on screen and thank you all
for watching subscribe if you want to
and i will see you all in the next one
take care
[Music]